hello there from a very angry squirrel
to the greatest Easter Egg book
collection you will ever see here are 25
Secrets Easter eggs and amazing details
you can find in God of War Ragnarok I'll
be sure to put anything which could be a
spoiler at the end of the video just in
case you haven't finished yet let's
start with an amazing detail during the
fight with Thor at the start of the game
Kratos does this a sweet right to the
jaw and the God of Thunder dislodges a
tooth Thor then tosses it to the ground
take a second after the fight to find it
and look it's still here amazing
attention to detail and should you come
back at any point in the game it's still
here Thor's tooth must be worth a
fortune during the boat rides and the
sled trips listen long enough and you'll
hear this conversation glad that I've
heard my share of stories about your
Homeland but I'd also heard that you
once fought in a tournament I fought a
mini contests but this particular one I
heard you did battle with beasts
scoundrels princesses the undead
automatons and History's Greatest
musician that's not that's not true I
originally thought this was a nod to the
time Kratos appeared in Mortal Kombat
but oh no I'm totally wrong this line is
actually a nod to the PlayStation
All-Stars Battle Royale game did you
ever play it kinda like Smash Bros but
with PlayStation renowned Brawlers here
listen to the line again I fought in
mini contests but this particular one I
heard you did battle with beasts
Scoundrels princesses the undead
automatons and History's Greatest
musician last night that's not true is
it so PlayStation All-Stars Battle
Royale really happened in the life of
Kratos wow what law I wonder if he
really played golf too there are points
in the story that tempt us to do things
we shouldn't from eavesdropping to being
the god of Mischief for example
ratatoska the idrisil tree squirrel
works with us from time to time and to
get his attention he gives us a chime
place nearby if you're evil enough keep
hitting that chime over and over and
over again and the mild-mannered
squirrel will finally lose his cool and
do this
stupid chime oh oh dear I'm sorry I
don't know where that came from Loki has
a few moments like this in Asgard when
asked to leave a room by Heimdall and
Odin stick around and make things
uncomfortable for everyone
maybe if we just stare at him and say
nothing he'll get the hint and leave
this gets a little weirder as when we
leave we can turn straight back around
again and listen through the door
eventually this is said
I'm not joking son go
well now this is just getting weird
did you know he was this weird when you
invited him he is pretty weird a great
small detail are the cups the gang use
when dining the eagle-eyed of you will
recognize these as artifacts we found in
the 2018 game we sold them to the
dwarves and now they're in this game it
makes perfect sense that when at home
those chalices are brought out brilliant
detail did you know the composer of God
of War score is in Ragnarok bear
McCreery plays a dwarf named Rabe he's a
Bard himself and should you read his
name in Reverse it's actually Bear
brilliant isn't it and a fan is even
given a reference too it turns out
thanks to a Twitter conversation that
the Public House in Asgard the Black
Thunder is named in reference to a Super
Fan and artist Black Thunder pretty
amazing that the devs interact with
their fans in such a special way
all the way through the game we are
tasked with finding poems from crevassia
sell them to the dwarves when you see
them on your Journeys and then keep
visiting sindri's house the Shelf at the
back of the room will change your
complete collection of books proudly on
show for all these are all Easter eggs
to other PlayStation games and some are
more obvious than others but I thought
we'd make this into a game I'll start
reading the poem I'll give you some
visual Clues see if you can figure out
the game before I reveal it you ready
the poem with a USA outline is named
afterlife abandonment stick rope tar
black
skin handprint baby crying shower stink
death Beach grubs delicious bomb piss
this is of course a poem written about
death stranding a game where you can
literally pee on the bad guys if you so
want to you do you the next poem you'll
get from the cover art Eastern Specter
the proud Maple cries a standoff makes
three men fall and the wind moves on
it's ghost of sushima a game where the
wind literally guides the way another
easy one from its cover is tool and bang
steel and fur unlikely friends United in
purpose to heroic ends saving world
after world with friends at their backs
two clever automatons and the last two
longbacks it has to be Ratchet and Clank
Rifts apart more a book with a feather
and butterfly tattoo on the cover for
the bearded cruel father and his
surrogate daughter shall never know
respite from a life full of
that's got to be the most loved and
hated game on the PS4 The Last of Us
Part Two another poem horses of Steel
and oil and leather brothers who fight
and fall together they rise from beneath
a new day Dawns the future has teeth and
Yesterday's Gone you get it that's got
to be a zombie apocalypse like no other
it's days gone there are so many of
these I'll cover them quickly as this
isn't Poetry Club recognize this image
it's the emblem for the game that needs
a remake bloodborne Celestial construct
has a face every PlayStation fan
recognizes it's astrobot yet the poem is
all about the psvr game Rescue Mission
the game which is used to create games
dreams is here as to are these symbols
from Eli and the Horizon series I'll
give you a second with this one any
guesses it's the multiplayer game with
no words it's journey and lucky here a
book about baseball in the Norse realm
MLB the show is a big deal here Nathan
Drake and the Uncharted Journey has a
poem too and can any Elite fans
recognize this logo you got it it's the
Order 1886 Supernatural werewolf fights
in steampunk London not many people
played that game and the final poem has
an ink smear on it a gentle boy and his
brush found kinship along the walls a
reference to concrete Genie there's 14
books in total and I don't know about
you but this is the most poetry I've
read in my entire life so let's move on
over the course of the game Kratos
begins to soften and looks at his
history differently after saving the
lingbacker the accompanying text reads
to perform and act so heartless it
reminds me of a boat captain I wronged
long ago the boat captain is a long long
long running Easter egg in the games
that was also in the 2018 game when we
found the boat Captain's remains through
a treasure map the boat captain himself
was set to be saved in the original god
of war from a hydra's belly but Kratos
actually only wanted the key in his
possession and then let him die then
later when Kratos finally died he was
tossed towards hell but somehow grabs
hold of the boat captain who is holding
on for dear life over the river sticks
and it's not over in God of War 2 Ulrich
the Barbarian summons the dead to fight
for him and one of those is the boat
captain he runs around and doesn't fight
at all it's a little sad actually then
in God of War 3 a little note can be
found in Hell handwritten by the boat
captain himself it reads he could have
saved me he held my life in his hands
and still he let go and now in God of
War Ragnarok these memories are finally
causing Kratos some thought it reminds
me of a boat captain I wronged long ago
he's not perfect our Kratos but he is
finally realizing the things he did
wrong in his life and death
usually when we finish a game story we
move on to another game yet with
Ragnarok there are far more things to
discover after the credits roll if you
haven't finished the game now is a good
time to switch off have they gone good
Tia's hidden identity was a huge moment
in the game yet we were given a clue
from the first moment we saw him if you
had subtitles on the name Tia was
spelled tyr while all other references
to his name had the accent above the
letter Y this was intended to show us he
was an imposter among us all along and
when the real tier is Freed at the end
of the game his name has the accented
why a minuscule detail I don't think
anyone noticed but it's brilliant All
the Same by the way the real tier can be
found in all eight Realms after the game
ends so keep playing if you'd like to
see everything such as this should we
encounter Thor's Daughter after the
final mission she can be found with her
father's hammer and this happens
wait a bloody moment
was hammer and his daughter
I'll make you proud dad
well
good for her and finally should you go
back to your Humble Home in the woods
after everything you've been through
you'll find a gift from atreus
what is it
mementos
from a Tracy's Journey
what will you do with it add it to our
own his story is ours and ours is his to
your right brother
amazing touch thanks for watching I'm
Adam you're awesome see you next time
I'm broke it